gauthier rimouski on parle donc d'un
char lignée présumés avec 400 corps
découverts il faut une confirmation de
l'onu
oui bien sûr il faut une confirmation de
l'onu parce que on a déjà la
confirmation avec ce qui s'est passé à
butch à mes
dents dans ce domaine là les clés disons
les grandes dernières années ont été
décisives et parfois troublante et ceux
qui étaient déjà par exemple journaliste
l'époque savent comment on se mord les
doigts après avoir marché dans une
combine qui était celle de timisoara et
encore une fois là où c'est compliqué
c'est que vous avez même des charniers
inventé et loin de moi l'idée de dire
cela à propos des visions main je suis
pas en train de faire du du
négationnisme mais le le charnier de
timisoara avait presque une vertu et la
vertu c'est et d'accélérer la chute du
régime ceausescu dangou voyez que dans
dans certains cas c'est extrêmement
compliqué là
on est quasiment certain qu'il s'agit de
cela pourquoi parce que on est dans le
même cas de figure que butch à et abuja
face à une armée russe qui est
essentiellement dans ce cas là constitué
d'amateurs au fond de conscrits avec un
commandement intermédiaires qui est
quasiment inexistant ça n'est pas
justifié ce qui a été fait mais ça veut
dire que chez des gamins qui n'ont
aucune conscience politique qui sont
envoyées sur place
on leur dit pas ce qui les attend
cc c'est ça la fameuse opération
spéciale c'est pas la guerre la guerre
ans et on sait ce que c'est l'opération
spéciale les conscrits ne savent pas ce
qu'est et dans ce cas de figure c'est
effectivement celui que le le le
le transfuge ou plutôt celui qui a fui
l'armée russe un officier qui a été
interviewé sur notre chaîne par marc
perelman expliqué très bien comment ça
se passait comment même les officiers
qui étaient là eux mêmes dans
l'ignorance ne savais pas quoi dire à
leurs subordonnés je répète ça n'est pas
une justification de ce qui est
manifestement le cas c'est simplement de
comprendre que cette armée russe qui
repose déjà de manière intrinsèque sur
des principes de violence parce qu'il
faut savoir ce que c'est que le service
militaire en russie il est extrêmement
difficile de penser qu'elles soient
capables de réagir autrement ce qui ne
veut pas dire qu'elle doit pas être puni
elle doit être très très sévèrement
punis si le cas est avéré si c'est
confirmé c'est notamment sur un plan
juridique ça veut dire qu'on passe de
crimes de guerre et crimes contre
l'humanité oui mais alors vous savez que
les définitions sont parfois vague on
considère qu'un crime par exemple contre
l'humanité et souvent commis par un
pouvoir contre ses propres administrés
l'exemple c'est la serbie au kosovo
c'est la birmanie chez les rings à la
chine les ouïgours oui ça s'écrit mme
lemay crimes contre l'humanité
le crime de guerre c'est avoir recours
éventuellement aussi à ce type de de
torture d'exactions de viol mais aussi
quand on est dans un rapport inter
étatiques ou font ça n'est pas très
important les deux son intensité presque
analogues et ils sont souvent
subséquents c'est à dire que là on se
dit qu'au fond il va falloir bien sûr
établir la chronologie des événements
mais que très probablement il y à eut
d'abord crimes de guerre et ensuite
crimes contre l'humanité qu'est
répétition parce que répétition et parce
que cette fois dans l'esprit d'un
certain nombre de potentats russe la
stigmatisation raciale des ukrainiens
comme des cafards ça va vous rappeler le
roi ne pas tout ça est bien celle là
elle est entendue par les soldats ça
rend impossible toute négociation future
sur une négociation territoriale
totalement totalement et là je suis
obligé de reprendre volontiers
d'ailleurs
et même toute médiation pas que
négociations oui parce que si vous
voulez on est dans le cas de figure où
un embrigadement 1 au régiment tu mens
de la population de type fasciste
conduit à ce type de crime alors je sais
vous allez me dire c'est pas laisse
millions de morts de la shoah et vous
aurez raison simplement ce qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que les prémisses la
mise en condition les textes par exemple
qui sont ceux de douguine d'un soul cov
et ses sens des textes de nature
profondément analogue est encore une
fois ça n'est pas établir un parallèle
avec la shoah mais sondés des textes
profonds remaniements analogues à ceux
qui ont présidé à l'avènement du nazi et
ça il faut pas avoir peur de le dire il
faut pas avoir peur de le dire parce que
ça veut dire que d'abord la chose est
loin d'être gagné des rues sont toujours
sur le sol ukrainien qu'il y aura
probablement d'autres butch et
éventuellement d'autres idiomes ci est
le cas est avéré je voudrais simplement
terminer d'un mot sur ce que disait
olena zelinska la femme du président
zins qui l a dit récemment que celui ou
celle qui en europe ou ailleurs
considéré qu'il y avait des motifs et
des raisons géopolitiques à cette guerre
c'est à dire à la conduite parle de la
guerre par poutine celui-ci cette
personne est malheureusement déjà
contaminé par la propagande de poti il
n'y a aucune raison géopolitique il y à
moult raisons idéologiques
fantasmagorique racialiste oui mais
géopolitique si la russie d'aujourd'hui
une démocratie elle n'aurait jamais même
songé à prendre les armes contre
l'ukraine si elle avait eu un différend
avec l'ukraine elle aurait réglé mais
sur le mode de la négociation merci
beaucoup gauthier rybinski pour votre
décryptage merci à vous